hey everybody welcome to another
I've got a whole bunch of stuff to go
over with you guys today I did promise I
guess that there would be an evening
stream evening on the East Coast anyway
and indeed here it is so there's there's
gonna be a lot of different things to go
through I have a bunch of videos that I
want to play for you I want to look at
some of the latest polling we are going
to see what's going on by the way we
will talk about what's going on with
protests and protests continue and I'll
talk about that in a little bit
I also there's just so much I'm trying
to get Hassan [ __ ] to connect with me
and we can I just haven't talked to him
and so long so I want to do like a catch
up with him he's streaming and I'm
streaming and that's an opportunity
maybe for a little bit later down the
line in the stream and also I may take
phone calls if we get 25 members I'll
definitely do it I'm going to play the
Jimmy from Philly videos for everybody
he get I mentioned these last stream and
he gave me the okay to play them so
there's like a crazy amount of stuff
that we are going to be doing today and
I look forward to all of it of course I
welcome your participation that includes
if you are watching on YouTube via super
chat if you're watching on twitch with
the messages that can be sent along with
subscriptions now by the way where are
my super chats are there but I don't
have them here where was that
let's see here why aren't they showing
up in this view that's weird
hmm could have sworn that I had them
good ready to go well in any case the
super chats certainly will be showing up
and it's going to be an amazing thing
Zachary Monroe set one says if you were
to create your own streep a stream
platform to avoid getting copyright
strikes you should call it Pakman live
love the show stay safe everyone okay
yeah it's a Bri I guess reasonable name
but I don't have any plans right now of
creating any platforms for myself I also
Opie Pilar asking will I connect with
destiny I don't believe destiny is
streaming right now um let's see
hey are you streaming maybe we connect
later we'll see what Steven Kenneth
destiny bunnell ii is up to and then i
wouldI i would do a simultaneous many of
you know yeah a lot of we'll see what
the evening brings there there could be
a lot maddie i speedy is asking what is
Maddie eyes PVD saying Maddie eyes PVD
asking hey David did you watch the
Marquis Kennedy debate last night Joe
Kennedy's a joke right I feel like I was
watching an episode of Parks and Rec I
didn't see it I didn't see it and I
don't I mean I will I will try to watch
it probably over the weekend to be
perfectly frank because I don't I don't
know that I'm gonna have time honestly
before the weekend so that's that okay
let's get to some of the videos that I
wanted to play for you guys this is a
representative of NYPD I mean it was a
crazy speech that he gave earlier today
let's take a listen to it everybody's
trying to shame us the legislators the
press
everybody's trying to shame us into
being embarrassed
[Music]
well you know what this isn't stained
it's still got a shine on it stop
treating us like animals and bugs start
treating us with some respect this guy
isn't a protester by the way this is a
police officer disgusting trying to make
us embarrassed about profession so
resist resist resist resist bro oh my
god and that's all I have to say I'm
defiant speech from someone who has no
business giving such a speech and seems
to be completely disconnected from
reality so I wanted to play for that for
you I'll play that for you there's also
crazy Tucker Carlson videos from the
last couple of days and I don't I mean
it's like how much do I really need to
go into Tucker Carlson I don't know but
let's let's at least watch one of these
three you have nothing to be ashamed of
you don't have to apologize for crimes
you did not commit you have the absolute
right to say exactly what you believe is
true that is your birthright and now is
the time to affirm that right right out
loud when enough decent people rise from
their knees and stand down the mob the
mob evaporates these people are not
warriors they are vampires they melt in
the light when we show them we are not
afraid they go whoa I don't know I could
come last night minutes after we said
that the mob came for us he's the
victory spent the last 24 hours trying
to force this show off the year we won't
succeed in that thankfully we work for
in the last brave companies in America
they're a timid ated we're grateful for
that right but the whole thing did get
us thinking that we should be more
specific about who this mob is and what
they're doing who are the people trying
to take over your country cancel your
rights eliminate our centuries long
tradition of Tolerance yes tolerance in
a free expression
and the truth is we often don't know
their names they're mostly faceless
political agitators who exist primarily
online they're trolls who thrive on
cruelty and yet suddenly they have
immense power over all of us weak leader
is now reflexively bow to their demands
no matter what those demands are why is
that what's changed yeah but by the way
I'm not a defund the police guy but what
are they what's he talking about weak
leaders bow to their demands the defund
the police thing has now been going for
10 days and Democrats essentially said
yeah we're not doing that here's a list
of reforms were willing to do and Biden
said I'm not for it either like we can
argue about the merits of it but in what
way are leaders bowing down to so-called
left-wing mobs it's absolutely crazy and
then one other video that I wanted to
play for you is ben shapiro talking
about sports let me see if I can find
this this is just so bizarre where was
it
ben shapiro on sports this was recent oh
here it is
ok take a listen to this and see if
anything sounds a little suspicious
about it to you ok it doesn't make me
wonder whether inevitably we're gonna
end up with basically two sports leagues
whether whether at some point people are
just gonna want a sports league that
does not allow this sort of stuff to
impede the play or or get on the field
and people are just gonna view that
because I gotta say like I've been
fairly tolerant with this stuff in terms
of in terms of watching sports my entire
life they're only a couple of times
where I've really turned off the TV one
was you know when it came to Sports
Illustrated I was a lifelong subscriber
of Sports Illustrated my parents gave it
to me for my bar mitzvah that Sports
Illustrated subscription for like
another 1012 years I just keep the old
issues in a box I mean that's how much I
enjoyed it and then when they decided
you know what it's important for us to
feature Caitlyn Jenner on the cover
when Bruce Jenner had not been an actual
athlete for three decades and all of a
sudden I'm about transgenderism in
Sports Illustrated on I can't do this
anymore because this has nothing to do
it Sports and I subscribe to a sports
magazine I'm not doing this anymore
and the other is during the Kaepernick
protest when it became incumbent on
people to somehow approve of the hands
up don't shoot symbology that was being
put out by particular players I'm time
today to do the same with the NBA now
that now that you have LeBron James who
was willing to basically virtue
signal on behalf of the China the
Communist Chinese government but rip
drew brees it's getting to the point
where I don't want to watch sports my my
place of of comfort has been removed
from me and it may not be it may not be
restored until there are actual sports
leagues that they remove politics from
the sports so a couple different things
here right number one I have I don't
know why I have a hard time believing
that ben shapiro is really into sports
but it's like okay i that i don't want
to focus on that but something about i
just am not seeing it if you guys
understand what i'm saying but let's
skip that for now because it's not
really the most relevant thing isn't
this the way these free marketeers want
things to work in the sense that they
don't need to be constrained athletes
don't need to be constrained and
hampered by sports leagues into stuff
like you can't talk about sports or
whatever we have a market where he and
everybody else can choose do you want to
watch sports when you might be subjected
to a political view that you don't like
or don't you and there's no coercion
this the athletes are not forced to say
things or prevented from saying like
these listen to me I'm a libertarian now
I sound like these libertarian clowns
I'm further the non-aggression principle
and I don't want anybody acting out of
of coercive acts right the employer
doesn't have to coerce the athlete to
talk about politics and they don't have
to coerce the athlete not to talk about
politics the athlete can choose to talk
about politics or not to talk about
politics the viewer ben shapiro sports
fan right can choose to watch sports
despite disagreeing with the political
views of the athletes or agreeing or not
knowing or whatever and nobody's coerced
in any way he doesn't have to buy a
ticket
nobody has to like isn't this what they
want if you want
to go to watch if you like Green Day's
music and you show up and you hear
Billie Joe Armstrong saying screw George
W Bush as they used to say screw Donald
Trump and you don't like that you vote
with your dollars this is what these
libertarian and by liberal I don't mean
capital it could be capital L or
lowercase L you know it could be random
capitalization like Trump does or we
could be properly capitalizing or not
the L you just don't buy a Green Day
ticket anymore if you don't like Bruce
Springsteen's political rants between
songs so then you don't you just don't
go if he doesn't like sports where there
are politics he can just choose not to
watch and you know what if the free
market decides if too many people are
sick of LeBron James's politics that
they tune out then LeBron James employer
will have to make a decision about this
is a liability or it's not we don't
renew his contract or LeBron James will
have to decide oh I'm losing
endorsements my Twitter followers are
going whatever that this is that this
entire keep this book why does he decide
that Sports is is a place where politics
is verboten it's nonsense it's absolute
and total nonsense
Joe Raider says via super chat amazing
new footage from SpaceX oh that I want
to see let me look at that it looks like
it's actually a SpaceX account so I
think it's relatively safe to click on
let's take a look at what we've got I
don't even know what I'm looking at here
Oh oh my goodness wow that is amazing
okay very very let me look at that one
more time
this is the StarLink fairing deploy
sequence okay it looks like it went well
it I don't I can't totally tell what
we're looking at but it looks like it
went very very well javi Rodriguez says
do is it seemed pretty certain at this
point that Biden will do better than
Clinton I saw an analysis said if Biden
converts 1% of Trump voters with same
turnout as 2016 he wins 307 electoral
votes
yes that's my analysis no I made a
similar analysis but yeah it's Trump
can't afford to lose much we'll actually
do that we'll do that in a second I have
the electoral map and I actually I do
want to do this with you guys
momentarily if you're just joining we
have a big night planned we are going to
be looking at 2020 maps actually first I
even want to look at 2020 polling
because Trump has been so heavily
triggered by the fact that he's losing
just like everything so we'll look at
the polling first and then we'll look at
the 2020 map we are keeping an eye on
any number of different protests that
are going on although it's it's there's
two things going on I believe that the
protests are going to start slowing down
because the media attention is starting
to diminish and this is how these things
go we still have a pandemic media talked
about it a lot less over the last week
and people are less concerned even
though it's still going on but we're big
crowd in New York City peaceful smaller
crowd in Dallas peaceful the seattle
crowd in the top right is noticeably
smaller than the ones we saw earlier
this week we're watching washington d.c
Smithtown New York Dallas and Austin
Texas we seem to have a frozen stream in
the bottom Center from New York City and
then a different angle in Seattle also a
smaller crowd and that is you know okay
we're gonna follow it but there's you
know it's overwhelmingly peaceful and
not really problematic Oh interesting
someone in Dallas looking at apparently
some sod that was brought in and just
getting more of a landscaping stream
really just getting a sense of they did
it they did at the expensive way you
just bring the grass in pre groan which
is something certainly we've all
considered in in darker moments we did
have some primaries today in Georgia in
particular
the voting was an absolute mess actually
I think I might be able to find let me
see if I can find my own Twitter page
because I did tweet a video let's look
at that oh yeah check this out in terms
of today military so it's not like I'm
talking about something I don't know
about also I walk with dr. King this DVD
case in the United States of America
this time people can't vote people are
killing each other and candy I don't
have to like you but I respect you as
human being
people waiting hours and hours to vote
of course major voter suppression
happening in Florida with a whole bunch
of different polling places shut down
and it's it's absolutely and and
completely sick what is going on there
and so we're going to talk about that
tomorrow we're going to talk about Trump
going after this Martin Gugino or googy
know the 75 year old guy who was
bleeding out of his ear after Buffalo
police knocked him down a few days ago
we will be talking about that tomorrow
Trump spreading conspiracy theories and
and a lot of different things so then in
a little bit I'm gonna show you guys a
little bit of the raw video from my
garden where I did pick a strawberry and
I filmed a bunch of video which we're
going to turn into a funny thing about
me eating my one strawberry which is all
that my plant has produced and I've got
I'll just give you like a like just this
this is a still from it okay
so just understand how much this is
going to be wild it's extremely
extremely alpha behavior eating a single
strawberry with a fork and knife so
you're going to like that I assure you
and then later in the twitch only
portion of tonight's stream I am going
to play videos of furious trumpets Jimmy
from Philly for you you will be able to
see what Jimmy looks like and I have to
tell you he looks exactly the way that I
imagined that he looked so that's gonna
be a little bit later on the stream I
also I have not heard back from Hassan
[ __ ] but I have heard back from Stephen
Kenneth destiny bunnell ii and he is
willing to join me on stream today and i
haven't spoken to him in a long time so
i think we'll do that a little bit later
as well and you know i think it's gonna
be titillating for a lot of people and i
will open the phone lines wide open if
we get to 25 members today
membership is quick it's easy it feels
good and it confirms that you are a good
person it's the number one way our
program is funded it pays the salaries
it keeps the lights on of course
very very low wattage LED bulbs
perfectly cruelty free lighting in here
but you can sign up at join pakman.com
coupon code right up there in blue text
2020 now saves you 66% everybody gets a
thank you so for example andrew casa
needy has just signed up
andrew is new member number one so you
boop right there
woo did you see that and what i can tell
you is andrew casa needy is a fantastic
person and we will indeed open the phone
lines at the 25 member mark so very very
exciting stuff let me read a couple of
other super chats and then i'm going to
get to the latest polls which trump is
very triggered by andrew Dwyer says just
saw Romanoff debate Hickenlooper great
debate debater i wish more progressive
debates like he just did on the attack
often but stuck to substance very good
Matt Chavez says protester arrests why
aren't Miranda rights read I don't know
I didn't know that that wasn't happening
I will look into that
Greg Watts says I can't wait for Biden
to destroy Trump in the debates do you
think Trump will even bother to show up
listen I don't know that the outcome of
the debates is a foregone conclusion but
I don't know that we're going to have
debates this time around we will see
Christian gaffe-filled sends a super
chat James boo Chino says David I hate
politics right now and want to give up
following it altogether do you have any
words of inspiration yes abandoning
politics is not a neutral act abandoning
politics you are still participating
either way I prefer to participate by
actively having a say rather than
letting other people decide why because
I think uh I'm not gonna put a number to
it you know Biden said ten to fifteen
percent of the country is not good
people he probably underestimated but I
think I know better than the average
person I do and of course you know you
ask people do you think you're in the
50% best half of drivers or 50% worst
half of drivers something like eighty
percent of people believe they're in the
top half of driving skill mathematically
impossible right I get it
but I want to be participating in the
decision I don't want to leave
it to others for sure Joseph Jepsen says
hey David one reason I became a member
was to hear your Richard Spencer
interview in full I really enjoyed the
conversation and he plans to interview
others with controversial or dissenting
opinions yeah sure I think so I'm always
up for that let me show people just a
funny meme that was done from my
interview with Richard Spencer I think
that you will like this one let me see
oh yeah here it is let me show it now by
the way if you're listening and
headphones this does get a little bit
loud so I just want to warn you guys did
this you may want to turn down your
speakers or because there is a moment
where this gets very very loud if people
haven't seen this you might enjoy it
will you denounce Adolf Hitler I heard
you don't denounce Adolf Hitler when
asked about that Adolf National
Socialism was it was a it was a disaster
in the 20th century was a pretty much a
disaster yeah but do you denounce the
app I'm not a dog Butler I'm not gonna
get I'm not gonna get I'm not gonna play
this game I can't throw out historical
figures and I denounce them I mean do
you denounce Stalin dude announce Pol
Pot I mean look yeah that is just one of
my favorites I have no clue where that
came from but I love that like I just
love that it's so well done and we've
never spoken again of course Richard and
I since that day and that's okay with me
that's okay with me I really don't I
really I really don't mind that okay so
that's that we got that out of the way
other super chats that are Oh a lot of
things are happening at once let me not
get ahead of myself I want to thank some
people watching on twitch peace forward
has subscribed PP e trekker PP eat at
trekker has subscribed with prime Reggie
nerd has subscribed as has gitch
dinosaur Cal and been led well as well
as Duffman so appreciate those twitch
subscription
want to say thank you to Aaron Carmack
whose new member number two today Akeem
Hughes whose new member number three and
Carl Smith that name I feel comfortable
I'm pronouncing correctly and lastly
Nick Sanchez who is new member number
five today at join pakman.com okay
Austin says what do I think about
governor Charlie Baker in general and
what do I think about his response to
covin 19 okay so as far we have a
Republican governor here in
Massachusetts Charlie Baker as far as oh
wait a second I and I skipped some and I
apologize I'm gonna get back to those I
think Charlie Baker is okay as far as
Republican governors go he's not the
most offensive guy he's way better than
a lot of the people around the country
but he is still sort of a guy who sees
everything
he's a former healthcare CEO that's his
perspective his response to coronavirus
was okay it was in the best 50% of
coronavirus responses but he was still
kind of slow mixed messages confusing
messages in some cases so he's been okay
I skipped a couple of Super chats and I
didn't mean to do that
Sam Dean says g'day Dave super-safe
Solidarity marches in Melbourne
Australia the other day no trouble at
all it can be done no need for all the
violence mate agreed
Joe Grover the effin game cat says I'm
in California how does my vote make a
difference that's the that's the wrong
attitude every vote if everybody who
asked that question stayed home it would
make a huge difference and thus that's
the wrong approach to have Jared Aguiar
says with everything going on do we need
more destiny I don't know I I mean I
don't know what's going on with destiny
I haven't spoken to him for a very very
long time and we'll see
James Montalbano says think about how
stupid the average person is and realize
half of them are stupider than that very
well said by George Carlin James Buchi
no says it feels like I'm always on the
losing side of politics and whether I
follow or not things won't change
the way I want and I'm tired of fighting
James I understand that I believe we
will be energized with the removal of
Trump and it will really set us up to do
a lot more a lot a lot more okay and
then I got the Austin question Robert
Ian signed up and Erin Coolidge beard
says Joseph Gables would be impressed
with Caylee Magon Annie's ability to
spin very much well said okay let's get
to the polling this is why Donald Trump
is so triggered it's particularly this
right here this CNN poll has Joe Biden
up by 14 over Donald Trump now let me be
very real with you I don't believe if
Joe Biden wins he will win the popular
vote by 14 and I don't even know that he
will win by 7 but we could be going to a
historic electoral college defeat for
Donald Trump if we all get out there and
vote regardless Donald Trump was so
triggered by this poll that he hired
some polling dude McLaughlin to write a
letter hilariously poorly written
claiming to debunk this poll with all
false talking points but it's not just
this poll then the hill Harris X put out
a poll that has Joe Biden up by 10
nationally now what's really important
here is that Joe Biden is regularly
getting over 50 in a lot of these polls
in fact let's look at the National
national polls okay so as you can see
here just since the start of June
you've got Biden 52 Biden 53 Biden 50
Biden 55 now we're still very far out so
it would be normal at this point
although it's crazy to me how could
anyone be undecided it is historically
normal I don't find it normal but it's
historically expected that you still
have a lot of undecided so a challenger
getting over 50 regularly five months
out is really important now I want to be
clear people are emailing me saying
David you're gonna cry when Trump wins
in November you're gonna be so shocked
no these are just the numbers right now
we
need to act as if every single state
could be won by Trump whether you're
voting in California or Utah by the way
Utah's closer than it's been in a long
time you need to act as if Trump could
win your state and you need to vote and
by the way I've said before Trump has
been very good for my show
financially Trump getting reelected is
better for me than Joe Biden winning
that's the reality but that's not what
I'm voting for and that's not what's
good for the country and that's not good
what's good for the world so if Trump
wins I'll do better but I would still be
horrified so it's not you know I'm gonna
cry I'm gonna be shocked these are very
strong numbers for Joe Biden five months
out the economy could start to improve
or Trump could argue that it's improving
and he could end up winning or whatever
okay we've all got to go out and vote
now why is it that this is likely to
come down only to a few states so let's
take a look at this I'm going to set
this map hold on a second what is this
map this is 2020 oh is this set to thee
what are we looking at here I wanted to
set this to 2016 and there's normally
let's see Reese
oh here we go Oh beautiful okay 2016
actual this is the actual 2016 results
as you can see Donald Trump had 306
electoral votes and Hillary Clinton had
232 let's start with the big prizes Ohio
and Florida Donald Trump if he really
wants to be in this needs Ohio and
Florida why do I say that okay if Donald
Trump loses both of these it's over so
consider that there were these a bunch
of states that Trump won in 2016 could
be blue states Arizona Wisconsin
Michigan Pennsylvania Iowa sometimes
could you know could go blue North
Carolina could go blue forget about all
that Trump keeps all of that if he only
loses Ohio and Florida it's over because
that puts Biden over 270 okay now let's
go to a more conservative scenario let's
assume Trump keeps Florida but loses
Ohio okay so this is 26
from losses Ohio okay that puts them at
288 look at now how precarious the
situation is based on these key four
states Arizona Wisconsin Michigan and
Pennsylvania if Trump doesn't win Ohio
if Biden gets Pennsylvania it's over
okay so understand these are all states
Arizona Wisconsin and Michigan that
Democrats often win Biden doesn't need
any of them if Trump can't hold Ohio
Biden only needs to add Pennsylvania
it's quite possible that in Michigan all
four of the electoral votes would end up
going to Joe Biden let's not even let's
not even mess with that let's just
pretend hold on how do I do this
two and two wait one and one whoops
that's Nebraska what am i doing let's
reset that map I'm sorry okay so again
if Trump loses Ohio only Pennsylvania
puts Joe Biden over or imagine that
Trump keeps Pennsylvania any two of
these others Arizona and Wisconsin or
Arizona and Michigan or Wisconsin and
Michigan all of these scenarios put Joe
Biden over the edge now let's go again
even more conservative imagine that
Trump keeps Ohio and Florida Biden still
can win just by taking some of these
states Trump can keep Ohio and Florida
if Biden can win Pennsylvania Arizona
and Wisconsin he wins if Biden can take
Wisconsin and Michigan and Pennsylvania
he wins if he doesn't get Pennsylvania
he can still do it
oh no he would be it would be a tie
that's the tie scenario with Arizona
Wisconsin in Michigan so my point to you
is there's all of these possibilities
people are throwing out what if Utah
goes for Biden if Mitt Romney endorses
Biden or you know North Carolina is in
play it's conceivable that that Biden
would win North Carol if any of that
stuff happens this will be part of a
blue wave so big that Biden
rock it to a historic victory I don't
think that that's likely I'm not even
thinking about that what I'm thinking
about is Trump can't afford to lose
almost anything we already went through
if he loses Ohio in Florida it's over if
he loses just one plus Pennsylvania it's
over if he keeps both it could still be
over with two or three of these other
four states this is the math folks this
is data but we've all got to get out and
vote there none of these states should
be taken for granted and you know we
could look at some individual polling
like just for kicks
how is Ohio looking right now okay so
polling is makes Trump one bite look at
that Trump won by eight in Ohio in 2016
right now Biden is winning by one so
it's not even guaranteed that Trump is
going to hold these states I hope that
that kind of gives you a sense of why
the math is so precarious here for for
for Donald J Trump okay some twitch
people to thank Jay are dubs has
subscribed thanks Joey Jepsen as well as
PAC 3 htk I don't know exactly how that
would how that would be pronounced on my
website I want to say thanks to James
Dunne who is new member number six today
reminder the phones will open tonight
tonight if and when we get to 25 website
members I think that that will be very
exciting very very exciting
other super chats continue to come in
let's see here
Joe Grover the F and game cat says I'm
definitely voting I'm just wondering how
it makes a difference in the process in
California not meaning to sound negative
no I mean listen in a literal sense
Biden's going to win California right
unless everyone who thinks what Joe is
thinking decides to stay home that's the
danger of that type of thinking my vote
won't be the difference-maker what what
difference does it make well if we all
think that way we all stay home and then
Trump wins which is why we can't do it
Karsh vivek says you think campaign
donations will make a difference well I
mean listen
the candidate who raises more money
tends to win so in that that's an
empirical sense in which yes campaign
donations make a difference
breaker asks is there any chance Cuomo
will run now he said he's not running
Biden has Biden's the nominee Biden's
the nominee rad Rai has subscribed at
the SOI boy level the proletariat says
to ensure being a political should
police vote yes yeah I mean that's
that's wading into murky territory and
Baron Steuben says greetings from
Virginia thanks for the stream ok let's
get to a couple of other things as some
of you know I have an urban garden out
back and one of the two of the elements
of gardening that I've been growing are
strawberries and mint
now mint is very very invasive and it's
it's everywhere I contained it within
one pot because it's so spreads my
strawberry plant so far has generated
one strawberry and I picked it yesterday
we are turning this into a funny video
it's going to be all edited together and
I don't want to show you all of the
clips that will be part of it but just
just to give you a sense of what we're
dealing with here here is just a little
bit of what you can expect as part of my
big Hollywood production of where I ate
a single strawberry that I grew take a
look at this
supple spicier than I expected very good
really really good let's try one more
piece you get the right amount of mint
yep that is something kind of a flat
area where it was up against the soil
hard to be really hard to beat there it
is so that is going to be turned into a
big big big production
we actually have Noah working on it who
works with us Noah is put turning that
into something absolutely fantastic so
stand by for that that is upcoming and I
think you're really really going to like
the results okay next I oh wait hold on
a second did I oh no no okay
everything's like I thought something
just happened let me just check in and
see okay dad I think we I will still be
talking to Stephen Kenneth destiny
bunnell the second or the third a little
bit later but not quite yet okay that's
still upcoming okay I am going to be
playing something for you a little bit
later and this is going to be during the
twitch portion of the stream there's
this guy who started calling into my
show a while ago who goes by the name
Jimmy from Philly this guy is a furious
furious furious trumpet and we mix it up
he's in landscaping he's a landscaping
professional and I am going to play a
clip for you here this was one of the
earlier times that Jimmy called into my
show now you're gonna hear his voice
later you will see his face because he
sent me some videos all right take a
listen to this been a while since we
heard from furious trumpet Jimmy from
Philly I know some people in the
audience loved hearing from Jimmy from
Philly some people people in the
audience have said David please no more
Jimmy from Philly we don't want to hear
it
all right we have heard from Jimmy from
Philly and he is furious at SOI boys
sycophants and continues to seem to
misunderstand how some online social
platforms work take a listen to this
yeah it gave me from selling right yeah
I just got banned on Facebook because
one of your little soy boy sycophants
rich Louis reported me to Facebook right
what a joke Trump 2020 because you again
listen we don't even have okay that is
Jimmy from Philly I have video of Jimmy
from Philly I am going to play it for
you later today you were not going to
believe these videos from Jimmy from
Philly okay you are not going to want to
miss it because it is absolutely
stunning what these videos contain and
that's going to be coming up a little
bit later okay so stay with me because
we will get to that just just a little
bit later okay a few other super chats
are coming in let's see
Daniel test face is Trump only one
Michigan Pennsylvania and Wisconsin by
0.5% popular vote in 2016 I didn't know
that it was so close in all of them
I do believe one of those states was
only 0.1% harue Bacoor says kia ora and
well-wishes
from AK ovid 19 free out tarawa out aroa
New Zealand yes congratulations New
Zealand making major major strides in
eliminating coronavirus Beezus C Christ
says two different conversations police
brutality and the lack of empathy for
dark-skinned people by lighter skinned
people darker skin equals less empathy
there is some there are some studies
that point that way indeed
Madeline Welsh sends a super chat Ken
Clive says ayran chef pac-man yeah I
think people are really going to like
the single strawberry video I think it's
gonna make we've been looking at doing a
video like that very very strongly and
it is now in production
I see people saying they are calling in
right now and that the phone lines are
going of
yes the phone lines are not open yet I
will open the phone lines today if we
get to 25 members now let me be
completely Frank with you whether or not
we are dangling the phone opening in
front of people folks should be banging
down the door of join pakman.com to grab
a membership because it's so quick and
easy and it feels so good and you get so
many great things with it and it's how
you support our program fill it up
we have quadrupled the power of the
David Pakman show website it should not
crash any more when people go to join
pakman.com but in all seriousness you
know we joke around about membership
stuff and all of that all of these other
platforms were on as revenue sources
they are so unpredictable and the great
thing about membership is with the
exception of you know May I'm sorry
March April and May because of the virus
we just slowly but steadily grow grow
grow the number of members and it's our
most stable and most important source of
revenue so all joking aside we love to
you know have a good time I do
appreciate people signing up at join
pakman.com it's 2 bucks a month if you
use that code 2020 now and again I
promise I promise promise promise I will
open the phone lines the moment we get
to twin or shortly after depending on
whether I'm in the middle of something
after we get to those 25 new members
okay a Beezus Christ says even within
ethnic groups darker skinned people are
viewed less favorably
that's colorism yes Jews and other
nomadic people used to be darker skinned
legacy of hatred I I'm not exactly sure
what you mean by that there are still
darker skinned Jews now typically they
are Sephardic or Mizrahim as we call
them but I'm not exactly sure where
where are you going with that I want to
say thanks to Ernie Sanchez who is new
member number seven today at join
pakman.com and then let me see here let
me see if we can get destiny
Destinee I haven't I know that there's
some people in my audience who are
furious with destiny and some people
like destiny I just haven't talked to
him for a long time and I want to see
where he is on a lot of different issues
and he said he would do it but let's see
when was that 850 800 all right okay
that was 40 minutes ago and I told him
about 45 so let's see what he says I do
want to get destiny on and it's not
about you know people like or dislike
him it's just about what what is going
on with Steven so maybe we will hear
back I was interested in getting Hasan
Destiny [ __ ] the second on but he has
just been ignoring me today he seems too
busy I guess from what people said
all right so we'll keep an eye on that
Wells says seizing the means of
production one Barry at a time yeah I
mean listen this is a brand new
strawberry plant that I have and some
people told me that the first year I
shouldn't even I should just pinch off
all of the flowers and not even let
strawberries develop because there would
be so few and number I'm just letting it
rip I'm doing the Anthony foutch II let
it rip and we'll just see what I get
from it and I got one strawberry and
that's not bad okay let me see here a
lot of things are happening on discord
and in other places here oh she loves
you oh thanks to Marcus Arnold for
signing up here oh she loves you says
David have you seen those ingenious
Trump impressions by comedian Sarah
Cooper she lets me understand Trump's
incoherent ramblings for the first time
Sarah would make a great guest on your
show I love them I absolutely love them
she's fantastic let's actually pull one
of those up because they are so good
let's see here Sarah Cooper I've been
following her for a while if you've not
seen these these are so good this
whether it's ultraviolet or just very
powerful light and I think you said that
has a magic but you're going to test it
and then I said supposing you brought
the light inside the
but you can which you can do either
through the Skinner in some other way
and I think you said you're gonna test
that - sounds interesting
right and then I see the disinfectant
we've knocked it out in a minute one
minute and is there a way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost of cleaning because you see
gets in the lungs and it doesn't number
there's a tremendous number along so
it'd be interesting to check that so
that you're gonna have to use medical
doctors with but it sounds it sounds
interesting to me she's just so good
these are just so perfect let's look at
another one oh here's the latte the same
Lobster actually lobster the lobster
what I like less let me get to one of
the really good ones the lobster again
used car commercial Oh the bunker and I
was there for a tiny little short period
of time it was much more for an
inspection there was no problem during
the day and I go down I've gone down two
or three times all for inspection and
you go there some day you may need it
but you go there and I went down I
looked at it it was during the day it
was not a problem sometimes the Secret
Service even tells the president I can't
do this so you tell me mr. president
they didn't say to you you have to go
downstairs my responsibilities your
welfare they didn't limit you at all in
the house nope they didn't tell me that
at all but they said it would be a good
time to go down take a look because
maybe sometimes you're going to need it
and I've been down let's see if they'll
beat number two two and a half sort of
because I've done different things but
two and a half but I looked I was down
for a very very short period of time
very very short period of stuff during
Easter just very good let's look at one
more let me see which other one comes up
next I sometimes will watch these on
repeat oh the Bible this is one of the
best ones I'm wondering what one or two
of your most favored Bible verses are I
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when I
talk about the Bible is very personal so
I don't want to get into
means a lot to you that you think about
ersite the bible means a lot to me but i
don't want to get into specifics even to
cite a verse they don't like i don't
want to do this entire New Testament
probably equal I think it's just an
incredible the whole Bible is an
incredible joke very much so they always
hold up the art of the deal I say my
second favorite book of all time but I
just think the Bible is just something
very special
she's really good she's really really
good and those are those those are
really excellent she's really just I
mean there's something about it that it
just it works perfectly perfectly okay
let me say a few other thank you so it
looks like people are demanding the
phone lines be opened Jacob Frye is new
member number eight Alex Cohen is new
member number nine Jack Hurley is new
member number ten Jeanette Holly is
number eleven today Eric sane dawn is
number twelve harsh Vivek is number
thirteen
we also have Scott Martin who's new
member number fourteen and Corey McGinty
Corey you are number fifteen today
absolutely fantastic absolutely
fantastic
okay other super chats coming in Beezus
says I'm talking about all Jews used to
be darker skinned before the Ashkenazi
fled to Europe five thousand years ago
the nomadic Hebrew people did not look
like you how could any of my Jewish
ancestors not look like me how could you
how dare you a Beezus says sexual
selection / environment anthropology
David no I refuse to believe that all of
my ancestors looked exactly like me I'm
kidding of course I'm kidding of course
alright here's what we're going to do
next I've got the Jimmy from Philly
video we are now going to pinch off all
streams other than twitch and I'm gonna
play the Jimmy from Philly videos for
you if you have been wondering what
Jimmy from Philly looks like please come
join us on twitch at twitch TV slash
David Pakman what he says in these
videos is so outrageous
that it has to be on twitch because I
think I'd get banned everywhere else I
would just get the ban hammer dropped
okay so the stream isn't ending it's
only shifting to twitch twitch.tv slash
David Pakman come join me we will open
the phone lines hopefully soon maybe we
will talk to destiny but I will play the
Jimmy from filly videos momentarily okay
I'll see you over there and just